sophie ouest a fait de sa passion créer
des bijoux son métier il ya six ans
cette franco américaine installée près
de sombernon vend une grande partie de
ces pièces aux etats unis une
marchandise qui n'a pas pu être expédiée
en raison de la pandémie
dans ce climat morose l'engouement d'une
clientèle plus locale lui redonne un peu
de baume au coeur même si cela ne peut
compenser ces pertes
c'est vrai que la collection était c'est
déjà cuit elle aurait dû être en
boutique il ya deux mois les boutiques
vont commencer à solder les affaires
d'été pour passer aux airs aux affaires
d'automne hiver beaucoup moins j'ai
perdu la moitié de l'année elle se donne
elle s'engage beaucoup aussi fait des
recherches sur balles et des produits
des matériaux de queen oui tout à fait
c'est important de ne pas voir
disparaître une telle qualité de travail
même soutien 50 mètres plus loin chez
gaël burri cette créatrice a pignon sur
rue à sombernon depuis 20 ans et
désormais le plaisir de renouer avec sa
clientèle fidèle pour vraiment relancer
l'économie locale et faire travailler
une commerce quoi c'est important
pendant une semaine gaël a également
accueilli et commercialiser le travail
d'une créatrice en vannerie et d'une
artiste plasticienne orfèvre du papier
là encore une question de solidarité il
ya plusieurs situations différentes il
ya les personnes qui sont comme moi qui
ont un atelier un lieu qui a été fermée
d'office
il ya toutes les personnes qui ne
vendent quand d'exposition et tout a été
annulé et il ya aussi tout ce tous les
artisans qui propose des stages et tout
a été annulé aussi donc en fonction des
situations de chacun on a eu ou non des
aides mais il ya beaucoup de monde qui a
pas eu d'elle
ces créatrices espère que l'intérêt de
la clientèle pour les circuits courts et
des achats plus éthique durera bien là
de la fête des mères